this morning in our continuing bill of
the month partnership with Kaiser health
news and NPR we are talking about
surprise ambulance bills last September
an Illinois woman was driving with her
brother and her sister when their car
collided with a pickup truck well the
second shock was when they all received
very different bills for identical rides
to the hospital in an ambulance
you think you might have some control
over the car but you don't after a car
crash Peggy Doula and her two siblings
were transported to the same Hospital in
three separate ambulances
Peggy's injury a bruised sternum was the
least severe and my ambulance bill was
3606 which I thought was really high it
was nearly triple her sister's bill I
couldn't even get anyone to offer an
explanation
as to the different pricing
the ambulance was from a different
taxpayer-funded Illinois Fire Protection
District and charged a different rate
for medical services and mileage driven
Peggy was charged more than double the
rate of her siblings ambulances for
medical services and thirty dollars per
mile for transportation while the other
two charged ten dollars per mile so I
called the paramedic billing service
they basically
um
told me there was little they could do
that the rate was set by the fire
district Peggy says she's repeatedly
tried to contact the Pingree Grove and
Countryside fire district but the fire
chief has not returned her calls
I felt really powerless actually to do
anything to to change anything Peggy's
medical insurance covered 60 percent of
what they deemed to be the reasonable
and customary rate for the services
she'd received according to her plan she
was left that means with a remaining
balance of over two thousand seven
hundred dollars I don't have
tremendous amount of money that's a
sizable amount for me
we are happy to say that all three
siblings have recovered from their
physical injuries their financial
injuries though that's another matter
Peggy Doula says she reached out to
paramedic Billing Services multiple
times and tried to negotiate her bill
she also made a forty dollar payment in
good faith however the bill was sent to
collections paramedic Billing Services
vice president that's Michael Tillman
says patients must dispute charges
directly with the ambulance service all
right the Pingree Grove and Countryside
fire chief did not respond to our
request for comment but told Kaiser
health news the charges are in keeping
with the federal ground emergency
medical transportation program which
you've probably never heard of until now
Dr Elizabeth Rosenthal is
editor-in-chief of Kaiser health news
and she joins us now uh okay wow yeah
mind-blowing it's all mind-blowing
because you don't know these costs ahead
of time you get the bill after the fact
so how is it that a company an ambulance
service can provide the same service as
another but charge completely different
price well because ambulance services
can charge whatever they want and they
can join whichever Insurance networks
they want and you know what these days
most many if not most ambulance services
decide to join none so what are people
supposed to do I mean stand hop on one
foot on the corner and wait for like
neighbors to come by right Google are
you in my network
um you're kind of a Sitting Duck and
that's really the problem of the Peggy
faced I mean she was the least injured
and she got the biggest Bill and you
know in retrospect she should have let
her daughter take her to a doctor or
call the number jeez so when you call
9-1-1 you don't you're not able to ask
for the price of the ambulance that's
not part of the conversation you're not
even able to ask for which ambulance I
mean basically 9-1-1 goes out and
ambulances as in this case just arrive
and you don't know where they're from
whether they're in your network what
they're going to charge you when you're
actually in the ambulance on the
stretcher there can you raise your hand
if you if if capable and say please take
me to an in-network Hospital
unlikely to do so they take you where
they want I've always heard when an
ambulance shows up you have to get in is
there any truth to that no I mean I
always tell people you can say no now
the ambulance worker is always probably
going to say better to get checked out
but you might think better to get
checked out but I feel okay of course if
you have a head injury of course or you
feel really bad you should just get in
and not worry about the cost but um you
know it's it's really so unfair to
patients and this is the one thing that
was left out of that no surprises act I
mean uh you know out of network
anesthesiologists out of network air
ambulances are in but ground ambulances
so it was left out of the no surprises
Act is that an oversight or did someone
ask for that well there's some
speculation that ground ambulance
companies are Revenue generators right
for for many local fire departments uh
so that makes sense literally yeah it
makes sense literally but it's not great
for patients of course not is there any
way that a combination of auto insurance
with medical insurance can help deviate
some of these costs well you know 12
states require people to have personal
injury protection insurance with their
with their car insurance in that case
the car insurance Health protections
kick in first but for Peggy that might
have helped but also we've run a bill of
the month where uh auto insurance
Personal Insurance protection is very
limited 250 000. if you have a big
accident you can be really out of luck
that way so right you know you're really
out of luck one way or the other great
sorry fantastic sorry for the bad news
this morning but um but it's realistic
it's really a hole in our legislation
and it's really should be plugged I
think thanks for bringing attention yeah
I hope it is thank you very much